[Musique]
kébé mois
il fut une époque où les êtres humains
vivaient avec beaucoup d'autres
créatures y compris des monstres mais un
jour les humains voulurent monopolisé le
monde et déclarèrent la guerre aux
monstres les monstres père dirait furent
expulsés aux confins des montagnes
depuis lors ils ne furent plus jamais
autorisés à traverser la frontière
aujourd'hui une guerre civile fait rage
dans le monde des monstres le vieux roi
ventre pendant ces combats fratricides a
été tuée et pour totalement anéanti s
investit le nouveau roi monstre à
massacrer les anciens ministres loyaux
[Applaudissements]
mais la vieille reine est toujours
vivante et surtout elle est enceinte
pour échapper aux tueurs envoyé par le
nouveau roi monstre est sous la
protection de ses derniers fidèles
servant elle est forcée de fuir vers le
monde déçu d'après la légende ce bébé
roi tant attendu changera à lui seul le
monde des humains ainsi que celui des
monstres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à damas
[Musique]
oh
oui
pourquoi côté les tops photo
oh
nous
[Musique]
à
si tu aimes tu es plus chez vous le
faites à partir des trous là
[Musique]
mali 30 mo on vit tous dans le même
village et toi je vous rappelle que je
suis une fille lance le maire tard cousy
les vêtements la reprise et les
chaussettes pas encore connue vous ne
devriez pas tu étais comme ça
monsieur le maire votre at-elle shao oui
désolé
si vous quoi merci encore de rien ça me
fait plaisir
je vais les livres et tout de suite
grand mère grand mère grand mère
quel beau si on line thiamine tout petit
fils d'un petit fils le fils de ton fils
monfils et dan qian tang premier ep au
palais de l'empereur est ce que je tiens
dans mamma là c'est l'héritage notre
famille sont une éventuelle de monstres
se sont plus un jouet grand mère je ne
veux pas jouer avec toi crétins
tu ne comprends jamais rien comme à ne
rien faire ce n'est vraiment pas comme
ça que se comporte un homme ce faux je
m'occupe tous les jours je couche
cuisine à répéter les mouvements
spéciaux de notre famille aujourd'hui
mon misère tu es un vrai perdant ya rien
à faire je te laisse jeu par quelques
jours pour chercher ton père robert tu
cherches ce type depuis des années
abandonne enfin on a donc clairement
garçon est le héros du bureau de la
chasse aux monstres
quel genre de héros abandonne sa femme
et son fils n'empêche que ton père est
la première et paix du palais il talent
et c'est le village entier alors
protéger ses habitants est mon devoir
donc si ces temps de voir page d'être à
la hauteur
au revoir
[Musique]
quand les monstres non plus été acceptés
dans notre monde
le bureau de la chasse aux monstres
s'occuper de ceux qui traversaient la
frontière et ils ont fait un si bon
travail que de nos jours les gens ne
savent même plus que les monstres existe
vraiment depuis la dernière dynastie
presque tous les monstres ayant traversé
la frontière ont été capturés le bureau
de la chasse au monstre est devenu
inutile et à fermer les grands chasseurs
comme vous sont devenus des gens normaux
des serviteurs voire même des mendiants
mais aujourd'hui votre heure est venue
si l'un de vous capture la vieille reine
monstre qui est enceinte
les monstres voudront la récupérer et
débarqueront en force
l'empereur devra alors pouvoir compter
sur vous pour tous les supprimer
le bureau réouvrira donc et sera
puissant à nouveau alors trinquons à
cette belle opportunité
si on fait
quand j'ai été incroyable tu as vu
comment j'ai frappé son ventre avec ma
tête je ne pensais pas être si bon jour
je peux vous aider
[Musique]
délicieux
ici ont cassé la croûte à bet vous
tombez bien je tiens un restaurant là
bas on y mange bien vous verrez pourquoi
est-ce que vous tournez autour de moi
comme ça celle de bavarder avec boiteux
faut qu'on avance ne fait pas attention
à lui il est jaloux dès que je
m'approche un petit peu trop près
d'autres hommes parce que je suis son
premier amour
pourquoi est ce que tu dis ça à tout ce
que tu rencontres
je te dirai plus rien désormais il
rougit l'on regarde il est tout mignon
quand y loger tu dis n'importe quoi s'il
te plait pas retombée ce que tu veux moi
j'ai faim d'accord d'accord je viens
[Musique]
vous savez notre village n'a pas eu de
visiteurs depuis des lustres
pouvez vous me parlez de vos aventures
te raconterai tout ça pendant que je te
mangerais farissi nous y voilà entrée
asseyez vous permettez je reviens tout
de suite je vais vous chercher de l'eau
fraîche
[Musique]
alors dites moi qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez manger vous avez quelque chose
avec de la chair humaine ou du foie
humain dedans je peux me faire rôtir si
vous voulez bien cuit ou seniors g du
boudin 200 canards personnes le parti
qui a oui tout à fait d'accord
[Musique]
jeune dame qu'est ce que vous voulez et
moi venons jianmin son amoureux je suis
la somptueuse charmante et raffiné lille
ira voter chaque rang à l'instant je
préfère in ton vrai nom est trop faible
[Musique]
chico
des toros lidiés au tour maintenant tu
penses toujours la même chose ou si
j'avais pas été blessés plus tôt un
simple chasseur de monstres de niveau 2
com toi je serai niveau 3 après vous
avoir capturé quel est ton nom petit
monstre
[Musique]
mon nom et gao me cacher dans cette
satanée enveloppe de peau si mince mais
on a de sérieux problèmes on n'aurait
jamais dû venir ici mais ce bois te
sentais si bon tu ne changeras jamais ma
katako là c'est quoi cette vulgarité
soummam hidoussa au mitard mais camille
tabou beau bébé tu as raison tout est de
ma faute
[Musique]
sa majesté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez par des pièces
bourgogne ce sont les miens tu n'as pas
le droit lé tiens ton nom n'est pas
écrit dessus
j'ai tous les droits surtout celui
d'être payé pour ces deux là votre
majesté
[Musique]
il reconnaît patrick désolé mais je m'en
fous je suis le maire de sillage vous
faites tuer des gens des gens quels gens
ce sont des monstres des monstres bien
sûr des monstres recouverts de peau
humaine
ignorant les monstres voitures sont les
créatures des poules les ingénieuses du
monde il se cache sous une peau humaine
s'habille comme les humains et parle
l'humain mais alors comment jeu comme je
peux savoir si vous êtes humaine ou un
monstre aaa à aa
chez moi savoir le combat là vous l'avez
gagnée ou perdue mois perdent déjà si
j'avais perdu et aurait mangé céline et
j'ai pas exception et les faits non mais
franchement quelle question idiote
comment quelqu'un comme moi pourrait
perdre tu parles trop match cuisine bien
ou bien que je sois un peu estropiés
j'ai de grands projets vous savez quoi
cuisiner et mon troisième emploi idéal
elle deuxième couturier et vous
devinerez jamais premier c'est quoi ces
cuisiniers et couturier chez ag ni 1
[Rires]
[Musique]
pourquoi vous voulez rattraper les
monstres pour gagner de l'argent
et pourquoi vous faites ça seul à deux
ou trois ce serait plus facile tu veux
le savoir
1 parce que les gens qui en savent trop
sur moi alors tongs la langue parce que
tu vas vous préparer mon lit je dormirai
dans la chambre de ma grand mère
et si tu dormais avec moi je serais
heureuse que tu disais oui vous assure
lorsque je suis d'accord je vais
préparer ça
[Musique]
et les mois
vous aimez cette façon
[Musique]
ça va faire mal pervers à quoi tu
t'attendais jeu devrait crever les yeux
ce monstre ta cracher dessus pour
laisser une marque
ce qui veut dire qu'ils te retrouveras
et quand il sera de retour il tombera
dans mon piège
[Musique]
me coupa non-combattants compare tout
couac raconta
gignac ou pas
[Musique]
battre à tout faire
tout coup paf un gros bang il
au mas
coup la wii
[Musique]
le coni
je crois
comment
cora
je
à
quant à lui baba prochain troc a dit
papa tu es jeune tu arrêteras grave pour
pietra
[Musique]
non
rihanna mais je
the shy arnétois volée
chambre
s'il est
je crois
mo
m
[Musique]
combien y en a ici ou là un boulot
zawiyah ici koussa y'a pas toi qui n'as
jamais
il faut qu'on retrouve sa majesté elle a
dû retourner voir ce boiteux
[Musique]
mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez
je
au boulot ma [ __ ] ou nagoya
est-ce que vous parlez humains comme
loulou makuma it ou nagoya
[Musique]
on
ma
à temps
et
[Musique]
c'est presqu'une heure de dîner serait
mort de faim
regardez
on a misé
tu peux aller les accueillir s'il te
plaît
qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'ai l'impression contrite sur les
entrailles il est toujours vivant
il doit côté chair bien c'est toi
doucement deux solutions se présentent
la première tu es en simple pour neuf
mois et si tout va bien tu as qu on sera
naturellement impossible
un homme n'accouche pas je préfère
mourir tu espères bien sûr que je suis
sûr j'accoucherai pas si elle aura voulu
ça tu fais quoi là je fais une antenne
justice
échelon or c'est la deuxième solution
cette fois ce sera douloureux si je
cours vite du tout du tout mais je vais
mourir
non difficile à dire je serai tout tous
oublié ça j'aime autant le garder je
croyais était un homme après
l'accouchement le commerce de monstres à
l'intérieur d'être main excellent et que
je ne t'entends pas te plaindre hein
[Musique]
des samoa delà des prisonniers je vais
chercher de l'aide bougez pas je reviens
tu aimes pas l'intérêt que je t'attrape
ou je te tuerais pour de moins qu en
soit je m'arrache les yeux je te
couperai là non pour de petites filles
de temps ça le matin c'est quand même du
don tiago qui est là c'est signé ouvre
moi beaucoup d'étrangers sont venus
aujourd'hui ils ont rattrapé tout le
monde dans le village
je crois qu'il ne reste plus que vous et
moi
t'inquiète pas les montrer monsieur le
maire ne faisait-il vous c'est moi
tia où j'ai pas la même apparence mais
c'est bien moi je vous jure
monsieur le maire vous devez nous sauver
votre père a promis de nous protéger
vous faites ne partez pas non monsieur
le maire je vous en suis plié déni
[Musique]
il y en a d'autres cachés dans le coin
réponse
[Musique]
boom bass j'ai besoin de vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est à peine croyable
le village tout entier est rempli de
monstres
on dirait bien que dacian song a essayé
de vous protéger secrètement on n'a
jamais blessé personne
on est pacifique et végétarien ça prouve
que monsieur song la raison les humains
et les monstres peuvent vivre ensemble
détiennent sans respecter les règles du
bureau en public mais s'y opposer
farouchement privé ce qui est un crime
de haute trahison
nous ne représentons aucune menace
nous ne demandons qu'à vivre en paix
nous n'avons pas du tout l'intention de
nuire à qui que ce soit donnez nous une
chance je vous promets qu'on ne vous
décevra pas une chance qu'il nie
je veux la vieille reine monstres et le
bébé qu'elle porte
celui ou celle qui me dira où elle se
trouve sera libre oubliez ça aucun mot
ici ne sera jamais un traître attendez
est-ce que vous parler sérieusement mots
qu'est ce qui te prends qu'est ce que tu
fais occupe toi un peu de tes affaires
seigneur je peux vous dire où est la
prêtresse je t'écoute
[Rires]
[Musique]
scarabée dauphin
veux que vous vous déguisés en humains
pourquoi ne pas vous traitez mieux que
ça c'est vraiment dommage en mêlée
[Musique]
en mère est partie en faisant confiance
pour bien occuper du village une seule
soirée et a plus rien soit optimiste
tu as toujours un affaires intérieures
je connais un acheteur hashim khan je te
donnerai ben % des ventes
l'argent n'est pas la première chose à
laquelle je pense en ce moment waouh
c'est beau je t'admire alors ce sera des
pur sang négociations terminées
[Musique]
bon
on
[Musique]
non mais tu vas arrêter de manger
si ça continue je vais subir des pertes
mois depuis le début orale n'a pas donné
roj
vous portez pas il y aura encore deux
bols après sauce aigre nom super être
ses jets la super héros monsieur alors
je veux te la super extra archidiacre
s'il vous plaît aux est super fort mon
dieu leur gangue directement j'ai
peut-être à petit tout vu le ventre et
prend un bébé ou dépêche-toi perçante
savatan que derrière nous
[Musique]
et moi
comment ça va depuis tu m'as volé les
deux monstres ou est ce qu'ils sont joe
pris la flûte pris la fuite
moins fort ce jour là tu te souviens du
monstre qui s'est enfui et bike porte un
bébé et il est très spécial
je suis sûr que ce monstre on retournera
tôt ou tard au village pour chercher le
gain du restaurant que dieu tu donnes
nous associer pour attraper ce monstre
tous les deux quelle est sa valeur face
à elle très spécial et seulement
peut-elle vous dirait que tu connais
bien le marché si c'est toi qu'il trouve
disons 100 à elle et j'attends qu'ils me
remboursent pas et ça veut dire que tu
es d'accord et
[Musique]
encore en train de manger et de l'argent
bah non
d'ailleurs est ce que tu es ce que tu
crois que m'avancer 5 ta elle regarde ce
que j'ai trouvé du gingembre confit des
abricots des prunes ça les cg non mais
ça va pas à l'oubli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce bébé moi donc tu me vole encore
comment tu veux qu'on travaille ensemble
qui m'a vanté cachottière
derrière toi
[Musique]
et un mauve car il serait collé pas tu
m'auras pas deux fois petites menteuses
[Musique]
longtemps nous aider à réfléchir si
votre mort vous touchera pas
[Musique]
je dis que tu attends compterait pas
rester et l'aider quel niveau 4 il
devrait s'en sortir a lancé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une chance pour une nuit s'il vous plaît
il ne me reste qu'une suite de luxe vous
la voulez oui
j'ai pas faim vas-y sans moi êtres
humains et monstres le bébé ce sera un
mutant mammites mais importe quoi j'y
vais surtout que je te prennent pas ces
tenues à chercher à manger dans les
poubelles ne donne un nom un bol de
nouilles ordinaire tout de suite
[Musique]
laquelle h
tout juste trois ans regardez le
craquant à souhait
j'aimerais tellement avoir un ce n'est
pas le vôtre c'est le fils du directeur
de l'hôtel
puis-je connaître votre nom c'est à
aulas nour mon mari et moi allons h au
piano pour un banquet très chic au
restaurant du paradis mais la raison
principale est que mon mari doit doper
sa santé afin que je puisse avoir un
enfant vous comprenez bien ling liu ning
chérie tu vois là enfin je te cherchais
quand on parle du loup mon mari jintao
zhang tao mademoiselle ou enchanté
chérie je viens de discuter avec le
réceptionniste
que dirais-tu d'embaucher un garde du
corps je te dis ça parce qu'il m'a
conseillé d'en prendre un pour la ville
et surtout ceux qui ont ces drôles de
pied ce qui pendent à leurs vêtements
ils ont une grande réputation ce qui
donne beaucoup de prestige à leur
médecin
bon bah je vous laisse discute et on en
reparle plus tard à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
attention plus à oui je vous rapporte
nom de nous qu'est ce qui se passe est
debout ya plein de chasseur de monstres
qui rompt vous qu'est-ce qui se passe
réponds tu m'as coucher je crois c'est
pas bon du tout ça pourquoi tu écoutes
moi je suis pour rien qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est ce
qu'on fait la terre va chercher un
docteur ah oui quel est le mot important
nous t'aimons sera trouve quelqu'un
[Musique]
je sais qu'on va faire des poteaux
inspire et expire lentement d'accord
c'est comme moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais que tu es là j'ai vite eu
contact avec mon pantalon des pigeons
qu'est ce que tu veux couper mais
regardons les yeux fermés couple a rien
fait
[Musique]
et attend ses attentions coupe parce
qu'à côté turc coupe maintenant ou à
traiter à coucher qu'est ce que tu
racontes
après bien sûr rien d'autre à koupéla
[Musique]
qui se fait déjà la gelée après mais est
ce que ça veut quand dans de petites
choses à penser moi c'est silence oui
puis remet au boulot j'ai l'impression
pour votre file oséo japonais très bien
oui mais vous ou dépêche-toi il ya un
problème car et en train de répéter ça
m'a tout l'air
qui est elle
ma mère votre mère peut encore donner la
vie quelle chance vous et votre père
décédé je suis si désolé pour votre mère
il ne vous inquiétez pas l'accouchement
c'est mon domaine
bien que je n'aie jamais enfanter j'ai
lu et entendu énormément de choses à ce
sujet je suis plus que qualifiés pour
aider les autres à coucher je m'excuse
c'est un sont désolés
[Musique]
ciao
on dirait un radis blanc à eau
[Musique]
sois prudent un monstre est un monstre
est mort bien sûr
[Musique]
vous avez besoin d aide aux as tu te
réveille enfin à la bonne heure du thé
évanoui ça va j'ai vu un cauchemar sur
sa dette
nous nous sommes désolés nous voulions
vous aider mais elle est réveillée elle
va bien et le bébé mais en pleine forme
comment va sa mère je suis un peu
fatigué mais à part ça ça va bien merci
je n'ai jamais vu quelqu'un debout aussi
vite après avoir donné naissance où elle
père du bébé
hilmar moi je suis là messieurs dames
tout va très bien merci
le nourrisson où est il je n'entends pas
de pleurs
[Musique]
[Rires]
oui new new new new bell miu miu a
sûrement dû aller voir le bébé est ce
que nos oignons est avec vous nous le
cherchons c'est pas gentil nu en jeu
[Musique]
c'est quoi tout ce bruit est-ce que tout
va bien
tomba le regard
[Musique]
mieux nous sorte de là m'attend avec en
deux temps
[Musique]
madame c'est encore rêver oui
chérif qu'est ce qui t'arrive
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
désolé pour tout ça
des monstres tu dis ça alors tu es sûr
complètement sûr je peux les capturer
pour vous si vous capture 3 je cherche
mon fils d'high tone sangle auriez-vous
vu par hasard
[Musique]
m
et à quelqu'un et
il admire fièvre il est brûlant
donne-moi ne saviez et de l'eau fraîche
[Musique]
j'ai jamais vu une fillette pareil
changions change encore
[Musique]
bouge pas c'est bon c'est bon
ou pas
[Musique]
et les mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la fièvre s'en est allé mais il est
toujours très faibles à on lui a pas
donné de l'est depuis qu'il est né
d'ailleurs faudrait qu'on trouve une
chèvre ou une vache mais où ça pourquoi
tu me regardes c'est toi sa mère mais
j'ai pas de l'ebre oui c'est vrai de
toute plateau sera vendu dans deux jours
mais alors pourquoi pourquoi tu t'en
bethel guérir quand il était malade
parce que si les membres vaudra moins
cher ça change quoi maintenant au lieu
de le vent mort de maladie
tu va le vendre mort de faim retourne
toi et vous aussi
[Musique]
voilà c'est fait [ __ ] on dirait que tu
aimes le sol t comme tous les autres
finalement qu'est ce qu'on va faire
eh bien j'ai une petite idée d'où je
crois que j'ai vu un bébé sortir de sa
bouche
tu savais qu'un bébé pour y mettre aussi
par la chérie je n'étais pas au courant
cherry qu'est-ce qui se passe
que se passe-t-il auriez vous quelque
chose à manger peu
qu'est-ce que je t'avais dit un monstre
est un monstre
ne bois plus de sens
tu dois apprendre
sinon on dira que j'étais pas bien
éduqué tu comprends oui là c'est ton
papa il n'a pas bien appris c'est pour
ça qu'il ne comprend jamais rien et qu
ils 6 bet
tu sais quoi ta maman a pas eu la bonne
éducation c'est pour ça qu'elle me
manque de respect qu est ce que tu dis
désormais tu mange des légumes et aussi
des fruits sains et ouvre regarde moi
c'est pour chevaux heureusement pour eux
que tu as encore qu un appétit de bébé
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu le quittes jamais ça vient de ton
amoureux mon père me l'a donnée quand
j'avais 12 ans il a dit qu'à chaque fois
que j'aurai peur si j'en joue il sera là
et est-ce que tu l'a essayé mon père ne
m'a jamais appris comment jouer c'était
la dernière fois que je voyais qu'est ce
qui lui arrive est un monstre l'a tué
mon père était un chasseur de monstres à
l'époque quand j'étais enfant ma mère a
disparu
papa m'a emmené à yongning est il mis à
l'essai il est reparti tout seul je ne
veux pas vacant banon
finalement les habitants de yongning
sont comme ma famille des de ces
nouvelles rate parlons plus de lui et il
a abandonné son fils cet homme n'est pas
apte à être père tu vois surtout les
montres est mauvais même ce petit là
sera un vrai cap pâtisserie haut et
laisse moi te prendre
non
parti chama sur haïti une geisha croire
croire gilles coignus
[Musique]
pourquoi es tu
sur cette chaîne
chelsea
[Musique]
non
john's accueil aux mines
[Musique]
j'ai
shijiazhuang coinchée
le chili
jeudi
c
si oui ou non
m
tunis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
savoureux
[Musique]
je la sors on veut aujourd'hui ça va
faire mal
je voulais et attendais pong petit
chanceux j'ai bon et de quatre dong joly
à vous de jouer
allez c'est votre tour
on vous attend gagné non mais vous fait
gagner encore cinq tuiles defazio lieu
de quatre montrez moi vos mains est ce
qu'on les vins oui de vous
vous voulez faire des affaires non
[Musique]
tu ressembles un gros radis ou disons 50
à lannemezan et donnez moi votre prix je
sais ce qu'il peut valoir
mais en votant pas elle
mettez le dans la cage et attendez moi
là
au revoir t'es qu'une brute
je m'occupe de ça on t'as même pas
donner de noms si vous regardez des
bichons nouveau tournoi
[Musique]
on joue à cache cache
je vais compter jusqu'à trois et j'irai
me cacher là bas et toi tu iras dans
cette cage
ensuite elle ne cherchera pas compris
après un deux trois
[Musique]
non tu dois te cacher dans la cage je te
montre un
[Musique]
on recommence allez je raconte l'un
d'eux pourquoi est ce que tu es si
méchante tu veux le garder
ouais encore quelques jours ce serait
bien encore quelques jours
le résultat sera même quand on reviendra
[Musique]
regarde il pleure tu délires
c'est un monstre quelle émotion et
pourrait avoir il nous suit toujours
c'est pas une émotion ça c'est normal
qui te suivent tu te coupent les doigts
pour nourrir avec ton sang donne de
l'air très cher et elle te suivra aussi
pauvre crétin qui dit qu'une chèvre n'a
pas d'émotions pourquoi tu penses que
seuls les humains en ont et même s'il en
a pas moi j'en ai
c'est n'importe quoi les monstres et les
humains ne ne cohabitent pas un problème
[Musique]
pardon
la première vente
j'étais comme un fou et tp vous
inquiétez pas vous vous habituerez aller
[Musique]
qui
je sais ouvrez la pgo bas
oh
[Musique]
touche
est ce que tu sais jouer au mahjong
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce
e
on sait où est notre petit monstre
tuez-moi si vous lui êtes vous m'en
direz notre clément je vous le dirai si
vous gagnez à vous de jouer est moins
vite moins vite j'ai pas le temps de
réfléchir
allez ouste et pêche j'ai tout qu'est ce
que je dois faire
trésor fait la sabam gagner gagner oui
ça arnaqueurs où est notre monstre gelé
fendue au restaurant du paradis à
connaître nos revenus pour pouvoir
accéder aux cuisines foire mot de passe
je voulais pas tonné
[Musique]
et les mois
je
digard doigt est ce que tu viens comment
ça se fait que tu portes paquebot sur
toi pas étonnant que tu sois fait
attraper regarde la mienne comme elle
est si souple et si doux si la mienne
fille et la ch'ti tu regardes pas de
couture pas de colle rien du tout goûté
joue c'est pas beau ça
est ce que tu en veux une propos ont
relevé les mois non on allait manger de
monstres l'importance
[Musique]
j'ai failli avoir une crise cardiaque
faites gaffe aujourd'hui nos cuisines
ont des monstres particulier et
délicieux quoi encore qu'est-ce qui se
passe un grand chef
nous n'arrivons pas à ouvrir ce monstre
tu pourrais coopérer hors de question
écoute tous les monstres mère un jour ou
l'autre c'est une question de temps ali
soient courageux étaient tombés
bourgmestre tu verras voulu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
sashimi de monstres quelque soit notre
grand chef arrêté petit côté qu'est ce
qui se passe avec ces deux là ils
refusent d'enlever leur peau vous êtes
éblouissante grands chefs et votre
beauté intérieure l'est tout autant
s'il vous plaît laissez nous partir
bonté divine second c'est un sacré beau
parleur si tu grandis tu feras du mal à
beaucoup d'innocents
mieux vaut te manger maintenant comment
chef est-ce que vous pouvez nous cuir au
lieu de nous servir coup s'il vous plaît
comme l emia d'accord va te faire
tremper dans une marinade cette nuit ça
doit amener les tragiques grand chef
fait en sorte de nous guérir
suffisamment vous pouvez compter sur moi
vous serez tous les deux dans ma recette
spéciale de pot-au-feu
ma préférée quand je non ça alors le
célèbre petit roi monstre qui va être
mon chef-d'oeuvre friture entendu
pas de bêtises gao
on y est presque seniors joue madame
doux soyez les bienvenus
[Musique]
on sent ce que tu peux être maigre
tu m'aurais protéger le visage si tu
avais tes gros test pour moi rien
madame oui vous êtes ici pour raisons
sont faits pour vous divertir je
n'écoutais pas je lis je vais aux
toilettes
la dame et c'est moi vous montrer
quelque chose luongo a porté aussi s'il
vous plaît
j'ai peur des chiens vous ayez crainte
n'est pas méchant les chats sont plus ma
tasse de thé alors nous n'avons plus
grand chose à me dire
doivent être servies allons-y et c'est
par là par la bien aller aulas attend il
ne nous a jamais vu avec notre peau il
ne peut pas nous reconnaître au maire
ou 2 passes 1 2 3 faut 9 2 1
faux répond j'aimerais attendez j'ai
habité honorable par ici s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
si tu es membres noirs site avait été un
gros jets souffrirait six mois en ce
moment nous avons comme premier hors
d'oeuvre des oreilles de monstres à
l'huile pour réussir ce plat vous devez
pendre les monstres à l'envers et sur le
côté droit pendant au moins trois jours
et trois nuits afin que le sang se
retrouvent massivement dans l'oreille
droite ensuite coupé très finement juste
le coin de l'oreille je vous vois hésité
il ya un problème je je dois aller aux
toilettes ça se commande pas ces choses
là je pensais que nous aurions
l'héritier pour les 300 tel de plus
aujourd'hui vous êtes tous très chanceux
le petit roy monstre est au menu
on le prépare en cuisine ça alors c'est
un très grand jour
mais avant ce plat exceptionnel
je crois que moi aussi je vais aller aux
toilettes excusez moi
j j
à la vapeur
on fait une bonne équipe
tchika cherchant les cuisines
[Musique]
ouvrez le tout de suite
toujours vivant
c'est pas juste les fais de mon mieux
il rentre chez moi je le vois mal
[Musique]
comment sont super branché et mon visage
j'ai enfin trouvé du tout grand chef
avoir un masque est bon dans votre coup
j'étais plus jeune ou quelqu'un pour
deux jours
on peut le servir que de cette façon
[Musique]
xiao
je suis désolé si on est dans la cuisine
sur vous monsieur le maire je savais qu
vos guerriers cabine derrière toi
[Musique]
que tu fais coup je les ai abandonnés
une fois je leur ferai pas je ne peux
pas pas de ce type
dommage tu vas te faire tuer
[Musique]
papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es une chasseuse de monstres pourquoi
tête ceci dit je l'ait pas que c'est
beaucoup
[Musique]
t'es sérieux son sujet de ce que tu
viens de dire
mon père m'a dit que c'est un homme et
une femme sans grasset il devait se
marier alors on peut et on peut pas non
juste optivision du rigoles ou quoi
je suis la seule qui reste de la famille
pour la responsabilité d'agrandir ma
famille et d'avoir des enfants et
maintenant la tienne ce simple rapide
mais assure que non nous ne sommes plus
si jeune je sais je suis sous pression
moi aussi nous ferons de notre mieux
partez à l'est tiao en mai lors de ma
vue dépêchez-vous vite
bonne chance et avis pas de mourir j'ai
pas fini tu me disputer avec tout
partait
[Musique]
pourquoi seuls sont pris à moi
abordée
tantôt libère tous les autres et sauvez
vous compte sur moi
à bientôt
oui à bien tous soient prudentes urnes
il
[Musique]
c'est notre petit roi
rave il faut revoir on a une mission
très importante laissée nous s'il vous
plaît dans vos rêves
[Musique]
certes on le garde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu fais venir on sera toi aussi
manger ça vous avez devant vous le plat
principal du banquet de la cervelle crû
de bébert wamunyini ce plat apportent
longue vie et empêche le vieillissement
clair il est vivant il bouge ses
meilleurs quand ces vivants ya plus de
savard on lui donne d'abord du vin pour
le rendre à demi livre et ensuite on
fait un grand trou au sommet de son
crâne
la meilleure façon de déguster ce plat
est simplement de manger sa cervelle
tant qu'elle est fraîche
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais là tu la connais
attention elle est louche c'est un
monstre je vais m'en occuper
ah oui rien grand mère elle vient de t d
la grand mère tu es ici pourquoi des
personnes m'ont dit que mon fils
pourrait être là et qui êtes vous sûr
ning et chez qui elle je suis votre
petite-fille par alliance ne dit pas
chantier vient par là toi etc aux
canines ton père elle c'est cette pile
pour toi elle va pouvoir énorme et plus
entre nous j'ai pas trouvé mieux pour
découper les légumes d'affûtage elle
découpera les monstres en rondelles
c'est sûr grand mère comment l'église on
utilise du sens et je dis ça au fait que
garçons derrière je le connais c'est un
idiot un bon frère non grand mère et
fils ont filtré vite à un plus tard dans
mr
[Musique]
et les mois
ce magnifique scarabée de feu est un
expert en ouverture de crâne de monstres
n'oubliez pas de boire aussi le sens de
notre petit roi ses bienfaits sur la
santé sont eux aussi étonnant
[Musique]
moi
si vous troublez te manquer
[Musique]
barton
ou des parts et pan je peux pas t'aider
non certainement pas contre lui
festoient série c'est dangereux
[Musique]
je pensais que tu étais plus forte que
ça mais tu n'es qu'un médiocre chasseurs
de niveau de vie
des grands
10 qu'est-ce que cela fait-il c'est le
niveau le plus élevé chez les chasseurs
de monstres
depuis qu'ils existent seulement trois
personnes ont réussi à l'atteindre au
repos puis-je connaître votre nom a
montré ce faire et pour était jane
dianjiang le chef fondateur du bureau de
la chasse aux monstres monfils deadline
tyan son premier ep au palais de
l'empereur
quant à mon petit-fils ianine filaire il
est personne maintenant fait
connaissance tout de suite ma
petite-fille par alliance
vous êtes de niveau 10 alors faites le
vous même sauf si peut-être vous n'êtes
qu'une vulgaire menteuse
to be
qu'est-ce que j'en bave au comme ça ils
ne sont pas moins et mon mari mon avis
si c'est mon fils en habits simples avec
yes no 6 + 5 pèse non 10 comme bing sont
si tu me rends le petit monstre tout de
suite je les libère
si tu ne te montre pas je tuerai ta
grand mère en premier et ensuite ta
femme pouvez vous changer lors de sa
femme en premier ensuite sa grandeur
bonne idée 4 3 2
ah c'est bon
trop tard
grand mère aux femmes l'une des deux
doit mourir à toi de choisir
ni l'une ni l'autre
[Musique]
plus de munitions
un monstre avec toutes ces couches de
peau c'est pas étonnant qu'on ait jamais
pu le deviner
je me suis déguisé en humains vers me
débarrasser les derniers fidèles encore
vivants du virois monstre maintenant que
vous avez à me désole
doré tous bords
à
[Musique]
oh
petite-fille par alliance tombe au père
t'a laissé cette redoutable piste h coca
légumes mais lui résiste
[Musique]
devenu pianiste son réveille toi
réveille toi je t'en supplie pourquoi
comme a déjà quitté s'il te plaît ne me
laisse pas sale toi aussi je t'ordonne
de te réveiller sinon je tiens à choisir
ainsi que les temps dont je te coupe la
langue niche des viseurs j'ai besoin de
toi
[Musique]
c'est
il
sur de la famille stocks
[Musique]
oui
on
m
voilà
autour ils m'ont sco régnant sur le
monde des humains
[Musique]
oh
merci
[Musique]
j'en ai un tu a comblé les espoirs de
ton père est un tueur ni cette première
pièce a été laissé par ton père tu
devras gagner seul toutes les autres
sont plus égales 10 selon trouve et pour
moi tu es sur une fois que tu auras pris
cette pièce tu seras chasseurs j'en suis
sûr biya is it was finnair grand mère
ja
[Musique]
ils ont déjà mangé notre bébé roi on
arrive trop tard
[Musique]
hu
ils partent à la recherche de terres
inconnues pour reconstruire un village
comme yongning celui-là tu ne seras en
sécurité qu'avec eux ils te protégeons
copains
j'aimerais vraiment garder avec moi mais
ce serait une mauvaise idée
même si je te déguise comme un humain
tôt ou tard les gens sauront et ce sera
très dangereux pour toi
les humains ne peuvent pas encore
d'accepter cela changera peut-être un
jour tu as compris ne laisse plus
personne tap les radis blanc même si tu
y ressemble beaucoup
tu as un nom tâche de ne pas l'oublier
c'est houba
au revoir
[Musique]
va-t-en
i
[Musique]
chatel
va-t-en
je ne te vas pas
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si tu laisse partir un monstre comment
est-ce que tu peux être un chasseur il
ya des bons et des mauvais monstre
j'attrape seulement les mauvais mais au
fait j'y pense tu es mon âme maintenant
un désormais tu feras tout ce que je dis
un combat où est ce qu'on va chercher
mon père j'aimerais en savoir plus sur
lui en août
attends je vais le porter
red hat c'est bon je vais prendre je
meurs de faim les arceaux est-ce que
vous avez quelque chose avec de la
chaire mail de da si vous voulez je peux
me faire rôtir bien tuer ou saignant 10
ou crois-tu coups bas et les autres vont
s'installer gens sur yon mais alors
comment va lui rendre visite
pour ces armoires son anniversaire le
nouvel an et toutes les autres fêtes
[Musique]
sommes hissés aux saillies bossi show
6/2 6/1 d'agde au minimum 7 6 coups
yu
[Musique]
seul
les sultans sainte anne
doux
c'est
we do you see is us s'adjugent bakou a
écrit martial
en somme pour ewan ces candidats
n'atteint ce seuil on ya deux jours fin
mai
[Musique]
domingo nous tous mais dibby 2006